welcome to this video I'm getting played
I keep forgetting played for a while now
so Bishop e5 e6 is one decent reply
Black's position is quite quite flexible
here one positive point is for me is
that it's it looks quite similar to
learn - Spanish - Spanish game okay I
haven't played it five but anyway
so how to play this I guess going for be
far before emphasizing the the diagonal
is a good idea the play before instantly
he might play Bishop f4 wait I can play
this anyway I've 95 I say we saw Bishop
a4 takes on c3 I mean Bishop c6 Knight
e5
okay so he allowed that and then now
Queen a5 how do you protect it
see three I mean
not at all
okay it's not only a pawn it's also the
dark squares in the center and this is
even more important Knight e5 yes this
is good
getting rid of this night and getting d3
sure so just take it or queen d3 23
rookie 3
yeah keep it simple
and no just 94 on that's some some
better way 95 is probably not bad as
well okay but the knight on d4 must be
excellent
Roxy one I can just take because of 92
this is also a nice trick
so I can also take here because of 92
this shirt should be a nice way to
simplify the position check
so should I move it I can get the night
back to a victory for if I want but ok
this is also an excellent end game
it's a it's an extra pawn I've got the
only open file so it's probably a
winning winning edge white very nice
yeah but early but it's not it's not
much fun I just have this this pawn and
the dominant rogue yeah I probably there
there was something wrong in this in
this whole concept here I mean he has a
hard time defending the pawn I just I
just take it very important is that
after after this I can take here because
Bishop c6 is 95 and black wins this is
very important and here I'm just getting
the pawn and I'm winning I mean it's not
just the pawn it's also these squares
that out that I opened for the Knights
you know I could take it III with the
Queen but this is this is just simpler
important point is this and here yeah
this is the easiest I don't need to a
92s even worse even better okay yeah 92
is better him yeah needs to give up give
up the exchange then but okay the the
rook
read check here is also winning it's not
just the porn it's the open file and the
second-ranked and this is too much to
hold it yeah thanks for watching